robbie ray if you take a look at his
numbers
he should be having more wins this is
his seventh start he's looking for just
his second win he's had four no
decisions in his last five starts at
three mendes earned on average at 338.
an off-speed pitch there and he strikes
that mccutchen looked like he took a
little off his breaking ball
bouncer back toward the middle off the
derriere of robbie ray
and that'll be a base hit for gene
segura
[Applause]
check swing ball in the dirt and that's
ball four they peel for the check swing
was that
they peeled for the check swing now pete
walker charlie montoya they're all
asking
about whether or not it was a foul tip
check swing
ball got away from danny jansen
i think they were saying the count was
two and two and that should be ball
three i think that's the argument and
they're wondering if that ball hit them
and now the umpires got to get together
and find out what the count was i
thought it was two and two
here is today's pitch
first thing you think about did it hit
him
it's a slider down and in
[Applause]
and it hit him
that ball looks like it hit his foot
maybe that's what joe girardi is
wondering about
well i i think i sonia when he held up a
3-1 count to gerardi i think that's when
joe said i want you to review it so i
think he's questioning
that
count
and i i think the one thing is another
thing that's reviewable of course is hit
by pitch you can go back and look at the
review
that ball is hit to right field of base
hit rounding third being held there is
segura
turned out to be a good decision that
was a pretty good throw by hernandez
so the bases are loaded four game
hitting streak for alec baum another 02
pitch
got it
the slider does the trick and ray
the second strikeout of the inning comes
with the bases loaded
another choo choo pitch to marshawn
[Applause]
what a job by rowdy ray
he strands the bases loaded it took him
28 pitches
well there's a lot going on in this ball
game early on i'm telling you we've had
a review of that strikeout this ball is
hit in the air right there then carrick
and his body
and opposite field home run for marcus
syria
before you talk about flipping the
script the phillies have the bases
loaded they leave three on and the lead
off man for the blue jizz goes opposite
field for a one-nothing lead
oh hits one high and deep and this one
is gone get out of here gone home run
for beau beshet
the dead center
second time the blue jays have gone back
to back with a home run simeon and
bishop did it on the fifth
of april with texas in the second inning
and today they jump on chase anderson in
the first and here's bloody guerrero and
there's a base hit for guerrero pulled
on a ground through the hole with
shortstop in the left field home run
home run single
green two one out guerrero's at first
not running
random gets jam and hits a tough little
play and singer boots it
he was trying to get bladdy guerrero
hung up between first and second gonna
play it out of bounce and then the ball
stayed down and went past him into the
outfield boy the philadelphia phillies
defense in this three-game series has
been terrible hasn't it here's another
two-two pitch into the breaking ball hit
the right field kingry's going back the
ball is carrying it's over his glove up
against the fence espinal is headed for
third here's the throw from kingery
it'll be cut off
santiago espinal gets a triple
and scott kingery has had some issues
out there and right filling in for bryce
harper ground ball base hit through the
drawn in infield and espinal will jog
home as danny jensen delivers an rbi
single
three-nothing blue jays sixth of the
season for jansen as he drives home
espinal from third
there's a drive to left field that ball
is over miller's glove off the wall
jansen is being stopped at third as the
outfield play has really hurt the
phillies here early in this game and now
with one out runners at second and third
gerardi will play the infield back
and bobashev gets a basement on the
first pitch jensen's in the score
they'll stop simeon at third
and the blue jays they got to hit the
shoes on today one two to guerrero
i apply ball to right field giggery is
back at the track he's got roomy missed
it he absolutely misplayed it espinal
comes in from third bow goes to
third base and that's a flat ball he had
room just misplayed it
runners on and now the bases are loaded
for randall just try and keep it simple
there's a drive and that's going to get
down and go all the way to the wall the
set's in this score here comes guerrero
and they're going to stop the oscar at
third and randall gritshit continues to
hit hard with runners in scoring
position
gene segura will leave things off and
he's had a very interesting day here in
the first inning randa [ __ ] gets a
little looper and segura whips on it
he's charged with an air and that really
started things off on a bad day girardi
makes a pitching change in the second
segura did not come in and get involved
in the discussion at home played rhys
hoskins the first baseman goes back out
looks like he has a chat and then later
on in the game segura and joe girardi
would exchange words dusty wathen the
third base coach is
intervening in the situation trying to
keep everybody calm here and that's of
course the job of a coach just to make
sure nothing gets out of hand until they
can take it behind closed doors but
gerardia has not been pleased with the
evidence segura has had a tough series
marielle's gonna have another hit that
splits the outfielders and goes all the
way to the wall as he will jog into
second base with another double
another that's a fair ball that's gonna
score guriel off the end of the bat
simian is going to end up at second base
with an opposite field double when
you're hot here
it's going to start with the number nine
hitter he hits it in the air to deep
right field nick may todd his first big
league home run
check off another milestone
a solo home run the phillies are on the
board here in the top of the fifth
inning it's an 8-1 ball game
and a line drive to deep left center
field gritshit going back it is gone
back-to-back home runs
mate todd and mccutcheon
it's an 8-2 ball game
[Applause]
this is trouble he's going to drop in
front of randall griczyk
boom will drive home segura with the
third run of the inning
well boom that's his 22nd rbi his second
hit of the afternoon
nick mayton's coming up
that one's out toward right center field
that one's pretty well hit and it is
gone
he's got a two-home run game
all it took was the first one
to then uncourt the second one
it's now an 8-4 ball game bases loaded
one out
[Applause]
pulls it on the ground natan at short
throws to sekka segura
handles it for the force out simeon will
pick up an rbi his third of the
afternoon and the blue jays have gotten
the run back
and he lines that one into right field
to base it one run is in rounding third
heading for home is
herrera
it's now a nine six ball game four rbis
today for nick maton
[Applause]
and this one is long gone folks
lady guerrero for the first time in his
career is homered in three straight
games that was a no doubter for guerrero
a home run his 11th of the season
and for vladi that's the seventh home
run he's hitting this spotlight
no one pitch coming to miller
and miller lines it to right field and a
one hopper off bridchek balm's going to
score
it's a 10-7 ball game
[Applause]
1-1 is lined out to right field going
back on it is great chick it's over his
head and off the wall they missed tying
the game by a foot and a half it's an
rbi single it's a 10-8 ball game and
bryce harper is coming up to the plates
[Music]
blue jays will stand two more phillies
on base and they hang on to win it ten
to eight and the blue jays win the
series two games to one what a ball game
do you have an hour we can talk about
this one and dissect it because we saw a
little bit of everything in this ball
game